a concussion is a type of mild traumatic
brain injury that can happen when your
head receives a hard blow your brain is
the most fragile organ in the body with
the same texture and consistency as
gelatin
skull provides a hard protective shell
around your brain
a watery substance called cerebrospinal
fluid surrounds your brain
cerebrospinal fluid cushions your brain
against impacts with the wall of your
skull during everyday head movements
this cushioning effect protects the
billions of nerve cells called neurons
inside your brain
neuron communicates with other neurons
through electrical signals that travel
down a long thread-like extension called
an axon
hard blow to your head can cause your
brain to strike the inside of your skull
during the impact your brain squeezes
against the inside of your skull sending
shockwaves through your brain
these shockwaves tear or stretch the
axons of some neurons this trauma is
called diffuse axonal injury or axonal
shearing
the damaged axons reduce normal brain
function by interrupting communication
between the neurons
depending on where your brain is injured
physical symptoms of concussion may
include headache nausea dizziness poor
muscle coordination light sensitivity
vision
ringing in the ears
slurred speech
and loss of consciousness
you may have mental and emotional
symptoms including disorientation
confusion
memory loss
inability to focus and concentrate
irritability
and depression
for a mild concussion your doctor will
advise you to rest and monitor your
symptoms to make sure they don't get
worse you may receive prescriptions for
mild pain medication such as
acetaminophen or ibuprofen only take
drugs recommended by your doctor as
others such as alcohol may slow the
healing of your brain
whether or not you've been to the doctor
if you experience loss of consciousness
a headache that won't go away vomiting
or slurred speech you should seek
emergency medical attention these
symptoms are danger signs for serious
complications of concussion